let's go to brandon joe the national
border patrol council president uh
brandon we're learning as well uh that
obviously the new york mayor isn't happy
with this but if you think he's upset
you should hear from the d.c mayor
merrill bowser who's dealt now with
175 buses from the border uh that have
come their way to d.c she wanted federal
help uh and so far i believe she was
even seeking it through the pentagon
that is not forthcoming but to your
point uh both these mayors and these
cities and these other locales where
these migrants are coming are they're
dealing with what governor abbott and
folks like you have been dealing with on
a daily basis
yeah absolutely and what really
frustrates us is when they talk about
wanting the national guard there in
washington d.c why isn't she talking
about stopping this this this problem
right there at the border if we would
control this issue right at the border
they wouldn't have to deal with it but
because the open border advocates don't
want her to talk about that she's only
going to talk about her city and that is
extremely frustrating when you look at
just two days ago we had a
three-year-old drowned in the rio grande
river we had a two-month-old that had to
be pulled out and saved and we don't
even know that that two-month-old is now
going to live this is an issue and if
she truly cared about life she would be
talking about solving the problem at the
border so that she doesn't have to deal
with it in her city but she won't
discuss that issue so where do these
people go brandon i mean when they get
off those buses
who's keeping track of them anyone
no nobody is i mean when we release them
you know you you just heard from that
official from new york city saying that
they had somebody that they had to take
to the hospital well that's not on
governor abbott these people were
released from federal custody the moment
they're released from federal custody
they're free to go anywhere that they
want inside the united states and that's
one of the scary parts of this illegal
immigration crisis when you have people
cross the border illegally and then
they're released into the united states
to go anywhere that they want that is a
reward for violating our laws and that's
what's drawing so many people that is
the magnet that is that is drawing so
many people across our borders illegally
and it's what's enriching the cartels
the cartels use this magnet to advertise
their services around the world this is
an issue that can be solved it can be
solved tomorrow we just don't have the
support of the white house to do it all
right so someone must give them a piece
of paper or something for about about a
court date that's how it was
traditionally handled at the border um i
assume the same procedures in place
where it's up to the migrant to show up
for that court date
it's a little different but the same
procedure i assume
in washington dc and new york city and
these other places how does that go and
how many show up for that
it is the exact same procedure it's
called a notice to appear this is what
we give these individuals now it's a
series of court dates it's not just one
single court date it's a series they
first have to show up to citizens and
immigration service and when they show
up there that's that's when they become
eligible for work permits or and and
then they get all of the benefits that
any united states citizen um could have
all the social benefits that exist here
when it comes to brandon they can't be
deported
through all these various hypotheses
they can't be kicked out right
not until their final court appearance
and that final court appearance that's
when it that that's when they have to
prove that they have a legitimate reason
to be here in the united states that's
when the vast majority disappear they
never show up to that final court
appearance and if they do show up to
that final court appearance and they're
ordered they're normally released for
about 30 days to get all of their
affairs in order and that's when they
disappear so the vast majority of these
people will never leave this country
they'll be ordered they'll be ordered
deported in absentia or they'll be
ordered deported um in person but then
they're released and then they disappear
this is a huge problem and it's a
problem that is easily solved we just
don't have the political will to do it
so even in sanctuary cities like
washington d.c especially new york where
they're providing them with all sorts of
things to just to help them in this
process there's no guarantee that either
sanctuary city is following this process
or following up on them through multiple
appearances in court
no the sanctuary cities absolutely are
not following up on them um it's it's
very difficult for even non-sanctuary
cities to follow up on the on these
individuals because if you look at what
president biden has ordered the other
way brandon when they don't show up or
did they just say no big deal they
didn't show up and they know they're
they're out right
yeah the sanctuary cities they they
completely look the the other way a
warrant of arrest will be issued for
these individuals if they're ordered
deported in abstentia the problem is is
the bite administration doesn't let ice
go after these warrants they don't let
them serve these warrants and so these
people know that they're free again
that's one of the other magnets that
draws so many people to cross our
borders because they know that this
administration is not going to hold them
accountable even when they don't show up
to their court appearances wild i always
learn a lot talking to brandon but
sometimes it's disturbing what i learned
brendan judd thank you very very much hi
winner brian kilmeade i want you to do
me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now